servus kids von herzlich willkommen zu
diesem kleinen roadtrip blog wir sind
gerade auf dem weg nach münchen zum
burger battle mit wir meine ich mich
selbst mit dem auto ich hab da hinten
aber noch mein monitor eingepackt damit
ich auch zu hause
ich gebe mich nachdem ich in münchen war
nach hause wieder zu meiner familie auf
streamen kann
also entsprechend ausgestattet fall zu
münchner hauptbahnhof da treffe ich dann
den derweil neben den mit erfolg wir
zusammen zum hotel und anstatt morgen
haben vielleicht noch was und ihr seid
aber ein solo leute da sind wir in der
hotelgarage bereits angekommen und wie
versprochen
kubicas auch am stabil und wir checken
jetzt meinem hotel ein gerade unsere
taschen ab und an gerne und haxen mit
weizen
der ist wie du all diesen jahren
trennten in einem ordnungsgemäßen wieder
darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen
und deswegen zeigt euch mal kurz hier so
dieses zimmer angefangen mit dem bart
alles hier in lachs holten die die mail
wenn es wirklich thema bildschirm so
sagt tag ganz nahe ist die stars für
wien so hier ganz entspannt doppelbett
und das witzigste ist dieser fernseher
hier habe einfach anhört ich rein
gelaufen wenn der stand so und her punkt
sei jetzt natürlich nicht in den sleep
irgendwie berlin von madcon im
hintergrund war ganz witzig auf jeden
fall sind wir sind gut präpariert und
hier ist die geheimtür of death aber die
schau mal nach er an erstmal hier der
erde aussehen haben wir noch so kleines
ball kirchen und einen blick auf das
graue grauen münchen
es regnet einfach werbe und altea blau
das bild auf einmal es ist gar nicht so
blau da draußen kamerafahren stark
lukas trat noch die liegen bei sich wir
treffen uns dann gleich und laufen los
in die stadt der liebe ich glaub ich
anrufen
es wird aber nicht funktioniert weil ich
mein handy im auto liegengelassen habe
mal schauen wir was machen windows
vergiss liebe zu reden ja ok deswegen
auch wenn es jetzt
was du hinter dieser tür verborgen sein
was kann es kann eine weitere tür
probiert einfach eine ansprechende
besitzt es gerade im
augustiner bräu haus
heute preis genannt
wenn man es ganz schön aufpassen
ein grosses kasino bestellt der kasse
hat schon gesehen jetzt versuchen
die bedienung mit einem work colts
kontaktieren
private sieg im ausland
aber
diese zahl kann
fellbach
o
durch ein anderer vogel heute okay
außerdem würde
ok jetzt weiß verfahrens noch mal
bundesstraßen
ok also voll funktioniert bis jetzt
erste gruppe von den spaß
so wird es nichts mit so etwas im moment
große
so ist es gerade mit karte zeugen wird
schildert hier noch
ich hatte nie geschmeckt und
besitzen
ich weiß noch nicht platzieren
auf jeden fall was wirklich sehr lecker
und emotionen etwas klein oder mega cool
und
bezirk
frisch bleiben
ihr müsst das bayerische erstmals
richtig lecker
ach ja wenn du das siehst du [ __ ]
o
die einen
leute ich wollte nur kurz fragen hier
mir wurde gesagt über die spricht man
ihr euch das mal über nicht wahr basic
bio genuss für alle das 30 darüber
spricht auch drüber es ist ja kein
dicker weißer sprich mal drüber es kein
ding mal ein bisschen spielen im zug
kommen
ein thema
und so meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren wir lassen uns den tag ausklingen
in diesem etablissement dahinten seht
ihr hier schreiben lassen ist etwa wie
ein puffer aussehen
nach der unsteten typen anzug davor ich
weiß ich weiß sie wollen dass die macht
so ein bisschen schönen abend